en el vídeo pasado dimos un repaso de lo
que es el exponencial y vimos cuál es la
magnitud de una exponencial la magnitud
de un exponencial es igual a 1 ahora
veremos con más detalle este exponencial
complejo y cómo es que representa parte
de un coche no seguiremos combinando
algunas de las ideas que hemos visto en
los vídeos pasados recuerden que una de
las cosas que hicimos fue usar la
fórmula de oyler la volteamos y
encontramos una expresión para el coseno
por lo que puedo decir que el coche no
de teta es igual a un medio que
multiplica a elevado a la j teta
positivo más el elevado a la menos j
teta
este es el coste no de teta expresado
como dos exponenciales separados ahora
realizaremos un paso importante ya que
voy a poner un argumento aquí que
incluye al tiempo voy a decir que el
coseno de omega t de ese tiempo y este
símbolo de aquí es la letra griega
minúscula omega y representa la
frecuencia el tiempo tiene unidad
de segundos y la frecuencia tiene
unidades de hertz o 1 entre segundos
cuando éstas se multiplican vamos a
tener un número sin dimensión y podremos
obtener el coseno de este número sin
dimensión
y esto va a ser igual a un medio que
multiplica
a la j omega t positivo más y elevado a
la menos j omega t cuando hacemos que te
sea el argumento de este coseno de aquí
que es aquello que va a seguir
aumentando siempre el tiempo siempre va
a incrementarse constantemente así que
vamos a terminar con una honda tipo
coseno la dibujamos más o menos así y
esta es una onda coseno que continúa por
siempre así que tenemos una idea de cómo
luce una onda coseno la frecuencia va a
determinar qué tan rápido sube y baja
esto pero ahora lo que quiero hacer es
ver algo muy especial quiero ver qué es
esto de ala j omega t y vemos que este
coseno de aquí está representado con dos
de estas cosas así que cualquiera que
sean estas cosas yo sé que puedo hacer
un coseno con ellas así que vamos a ver
en detalle qué es esto de e a la j omega
t sabemos que este es un número complejo
así que vamos a dibujarlo aquí dibujo
mis ejes ordenados
y voy a poner mi círculo unitario este
es mi eje real y este es mi eje
imaginario
vamos a poner un número por acá y
sabemos que cae en el círculo unitario
sabemos que su ángulo es cualquier cosa
que esté multiplicando a nuestra jota
aquí lo que esté en el exponente
multiplicando a la jota es el ángulo de
este número este ángulo es omega t y
conocemos la magnitud de esto que como
vimos anteriormente es igual a 1 es por
eso que esto está en el círculo unitario
y ahora veamos que tenemos esta letra t
que nos determina el ángulo esto quiere
decir que el ángulo va a aumentar
conforme pase el tiempo si el tiempo es
igual a 0 el punto estará aquí ya que el
ángulo es cero cuando t es igual a cero
conforme pasa el tiempo el ángulo va a
comenzar a crecer y a crecer cada vez
más básicamente sigue aumentando cada
vez más y más y más y regresa a este
punto después de que t es igual a 2 por
pi y luego que sucede pues esto sigue
aumentando esto se sigue incrementando
y esto va a estar girando durante todo
el paso del tiempo así que tenemos este
número complejo que se está moviendo
sobre el círculo unitario durante el
tiempo una y otra y otra vez así que
este es un número que está rotando así
que aquí escribo que es a la j omega t y
yo sé que este número por tener a t aquí
va a estar rotando conforme pasa el
tiempo ahora voy a dibujar otro número
aquí digamos que este otro número va a
comenzar en cero y este número va a ser
el ala menos j omega t este es este
número de aquí así que cuando te es
igual a cero tenemos el ángulo igual a
cero aquí y él va a ser igual a uno pero
ahora conforme avanza el tiempo o
aumenta el tiempo el ángulo o lo que
está multiplicando a jota es menos omega
t por lo que el ángulo se volverá más
negativo cada vez así que después de que
transcurre algo de tiempo
estará acá y cuando pasa más tiempo va a
estar acá y lo que notamos es que va a
estar rotando en este sentido esto es lo
que sucede cuando tenemos
a la menos j o mega te va a estar
rotando en esta dirección y va a seguir
así cada vez más estos números son
bastante parecidos en su comportamiento
con la diferencia de que uno va a rotar
en sentido antihorario y el otro va a
rotar en sentido horario en resumen si
se encuentra en cualquiera de estas
cantidades y al aj omega t positivo o ea
la menos j omega t lo que les debe venir
a la mente es un número que gira para mí
es una idea sencilla tengo estos dos
números y cada uno de ellos va a girar
en el espacio complejo y para
representar los connotación matemática
necesito esta anotación aquí que es un
poco rara pero nos acostumbramos a ella
que a la j omega t es un número que gira
y hala - j omega t también es un número
que gira
esta es una idea muy poderosa y podremos
escribir cualquier señal que ocurra con
estos términos